(wind rustling)
- Look at that beautiful rock, oh my god.
That's spectacular.
(upbeat rock music)
(wind rustling)
Wow.
- That's like my favorite
camp ever in Russia
in the Altai Mountain
next to the river.
- Oh yeah.
- Where we swam.
(wind rustling)
Wow, wow, wow, wow, woohoo!
Feels so good, it looks
so good, this ride.
- Doing about 41 miles an
hour going down to the Andes
and it is just stunningly beautiful.
It really is just beautiful.
And we are just chugging
along, it's very nice.
Back out of the snow,
which is quite incredible,
so there's barely any snow now.
We've only dropped, must've
dropped a few thousand feet.
We were up about just over 4,000 feet
which is quite a... which is
a fair old height, I must say.
So, there was definitely a lot
of snow there, so you know...
(wind rustling)
- I'll make it.
- Baby foal there, kinda cute.
- So cute.
(man chuckles)
- Skinny horse.
- Yeah, skinny horses.
- Wanna go ahead, Charley?
- Uh, I don't really mind.
Don't really wanna go too close 'cause
it's quite dusty, I don't know.
- For the eyes.
- I could test my water bottle.
Seems to be staying.
- Well...
- Beautiful, isn't it?
(wind rustling)
(rattling)
- Pretty jungley, isn't it?
- Yeah, it's beautiful.
Really beautiful.
Love it.
(rattling)
(wind rustling)
- Swim it.
(rattling)
(wind rustling)
- A big hole.
(man laughs)
(rustling)
- A couple of donkey...
oh, look, a baby donkey.
Oh my God.
I don't think there are many cuter things
in the world than a baby donkey.
- Hell no.
Donkeys and the mama.
(man chuckles)
That's just beautiful.
And the mommy.
How beautiful, huh?
- There's nothing cuter
than a baby donkey.
- Ah.
- Cute little baby.
- Amazingly long legs.
- Little man has got a sore leg.
- Oh, so beautiful.
So, we got 200 miles to go today.
It's 10, 11, 12, one, two, three, four.
- We're washing in the river down here.
- I reckon nine-ish, near that.
(rattling)
(wind rustling)
- Oh, it's the little dogs.
(man laughs)
Napoleon syndromes.
- Hello, little one.
- My legs are getting covered in seeds.
They're stuck to my legs.
I'll scatter them as we
go along and leave like
a trail of rainforest behind
me, that's a nice idea,
as we ride our way north.
(rattling)
(wind rustling)
I just kept waking up to hear
the rainforest all night.
I kept waking up and I
just would listen to it,
it was so beautiful, the noises
of a rainforest at night.
I could hear the river
gargling away down below
and then just the noises of the
animals and the insects and,
oh, it sounded so good.
And so sort of fresh and warm.
It was so lovely.
We spent quite a lot of
the beginning of this trip
just freezing cold,
you know, on the bikes,
and arriving places freezing
cold and it seemed to take
such a long time to warm up
and I'd sort of fantasize
about being somewhere warm
and tropical and here we are.
So, that's really nice.
(rattling)
(wind rustling)
- 100 miles.
Yeah, and this, the rice paddies could be
in Vietnam or Cambodia.
It's smelly.
Um, but beautiful.
It's so pretty here.
I just love this jungley kind
of feel to the whole thing.
Lovely, the palm trees and
the rice, the banana trees,
and oh, just beautiful.
Oh, look, here's one more of these...
There's still gonna be
shops with a megaphone.
You know, transporter shop.
Oh, a nice little shop going on there.
- Beautiful.
That's Claudio Roomty going by.
Charley moving up ahead.
After I've missed a
turnoff, was in a daydream.
Don't wanna hit a little power
line cable going that way.
- (laughs) Oh, my God. Can you imagine?
Straight off.
(buzzes)
(men laughing)
- Electrocuted and then killed, anyway.
- I had that once when I was in Australia
up in Queensland I was riding
dirt bikes with these guys
and we were going along
the crab tree thing
where you're following the power lines-
- Yeah.
- And I came around this
corner and there were
these vines hanging down and
I was wearing long sleeves
and basically they just
grabbed me and just pulled
me off the bike and I was
just stuck in them like this,
sort of sitting on the floor
just stuck in these vines
and they called them 'wait
awhiles' because you gotta wait
a while for someone to come and help
you get out-
- Get out.
- And they're like these
little vines with little hooks.
- Oh my God.
- They just hook you up.
And the guys I was with had to come back
and they all had to try and
pick it all off me and...
It was extraordinary.
I just love the name 'wait awhile'.
- Yeah.
(rattling)
(wind rustling)
- Oh.
Well, it's interesting.
We're now heading up,
we got our charge point,
which is about 80-90 miles, about an hour.
(wind whistling)
(man sings)
(wind rustling)
- Okay.
(man whistling)
(man sings)
(wind whistling)
(man whistling)
- Sure, well, this looks like France.
Feels like we're in France or somewhere.
(man whistles)
Hey!
(rattling)
(wind rustling)
Hey.
Careful.
(man whistles)
(man cheers)
Large.
- That's the way you do it.
(muffled talking)
(wind rustling)
Oh, this road, it is beautiful.
Up through the mountains,
we're now at only 300 feet,
so I don't know what that
is in meters, not much.
(muffled talking)
- Hello, hello.
(speaking gibberish)
- Might just figure out this tonight
how many miles it is to LA.
'Cause this is quite a long way now,
I feel like it's quite a long way up.
(wind whistling)
Oh.
Been awhile.
(muffled talking)
- It's so pretty.
Look how pretty that is.
Look.
That is beautiful.
Wowza, wowza, wowza.
That is pretty.
Whoa.
(wind whistling)
- Ewan McGregor.
- Stunning.
- Charley Boorman.
Explore great tunnels of the world.
Only on Apple TV.
- The trucks have got so many
lights and stuff on them here,
they really decorate up the trucks.
Now, there's a policeman.
Hello.
Well, the first jump and there's
a truck, then that's a car.
This is a hospital.
Hesparia.
It's not much closer to Hesparia.
Oh my God, okay, 60 miles,
one hour and 56 minutes to go
according to my Apple phone device.
It's 5:44 p.m.
Oh boy.
♪ I'm just putting on an event for you ♪
♪ Just a ordinary Sunday for two ♪
(man sings)
On board showtunes by Ewan McGregor.
(wind howling)
(man hums)
- I don't know why this is not working.
- I don't know.
I keep pressing it.
Connect!
Connect.
(wind whistling)
Oh, that's beautiful.
That's pretty.
(man hums)
(engine rumbling)
(wind whistling)
♪ Button up your anorak ♪
♪ When the wind is free ♪
♪ Take good care of ♪
(muffled singing)
(wind whistling)
(rustling)
- 56 miles, 57 miles, up the hill we go.
Let's get on top of the Andes.
For those of you at home who
are looking for the Andes,
they're at the end of your city views.
(speaking foreign language)
- I wonder where this
Claudio Roomty Poompt is.
I think he's gone on ahead.
(wind whistling)
- Oof, that's not a nice feeling.
Feel blah.
Grooved roads like that
catch your front wheel
and the front wheel gets sort
of, not stuck in them, but it
jigs back and forwards your
front wheel a little bit.
It's not a nice feeling at all,
especially not with those big
trucks coming towards you.
It's very grooved.
Very grooved.
Your road is very grooved, by the way.
Excuse me, is your road grooved?
Aye, I thought so.
I could just tell by the
way my front wheel was
flapping away in the front there.
That is definitely a grooved road.
I thought to myself.
Here we go!
Honduras!
- Wow.
- Yes.
- Striking out on our own,
the intrepid explorers.
- Yes.
- Try and find their way
a staggering 120 miles.
- Oh, well, you know, a lot could happen.
(man laughs)
- Oh, melons.
Lovely, lovely melons.
(wind rustling)
- Happy days.
- Yeah, it is pretty awesome actually.
Such lucky people to be traveling through.
I was just thinking, some
guy asked me this morning,
this German guy who was
putting in solar farms here.
- Oh yeah?
- And he was saying
are those electric, he said,
"Where have you come from?"
And I said we're from Australia
and his face just lit up.
- Oh really?
- And he was like, "What?
Plugging in the whole way?"
And I said, "Yeah, no, we really did."
And he goes, "What was it like?"
He said the transition
between fuel and energy,
you know, is very different.
And I said, "Yeah, no."
I said, "It's been a real mind reset."
- Yeah.
- And he was just
super blown away by, I mean.
He just said, "God, you lucky people."
- Oh, that's nice.
- And so I was thinking we so are lucky.
- Yeah, no, no, no, it's true.
- It's just extraordinary.
- We are.
With these amazing motorbikes,
there are only two of
their kind in the world.
- I think there's a
bit of wind here today.
(wind whistling)
Anyway, we've got a couple of options.
We can go to that, if it
seems to be chewing more up
we can always hit that town
just before the other town.
- Yeah, the one with the C.
The C town.
- Yeah, C-tala-tia.
Something like that.
(wind whistling)
- Oh, what a beautiful
temperature it is this morning.
- Wow, I'm hotter than a hot date.
- Oh boy, that's not a good smell.
Woo!
(man coughs)
(man laughs)
- It's always funny 'cause it's you.
Retching and gagging, I don't
know why that's so funny.
- Oh, the smell-
(man coughs)
- Oh no, that's bad!
(laughs) That was a bad one.
(man gags)
(man laughs)
What was that donkey?
- The donkey, yeah.
- That was really smelly.
(man gags)
- Very nice.
- It's beautiful.
(wind rustling)
- How many miles have we got to go?
- Um...
89.
It says two hours and six minutes
would get us in at 3:19.
- I've got 86 miles on my bike.
- I've got 83.
- Okay, so we'll
definitely have to plug in.
- Yeah.
- Nice.
But at least we won't have
to do it for very long,
you know, half an hour, 40
minutes will be enough I reckon.
- Yeah.
(wind rustling)
- Wow, we're above the clouds.
Oh my gosh, look at this.
The change in scenery, it's just...
It's just extraordinary.
It's become quite arid now, you know,
sort of that bit in between
desert and jungle where,
you know, all the trees here
are much lower and shorter
and you know, 'cause everything
takes longer to grow.
And it's really quite pretty.
And the rolling hills, it's very,
I think it's very different to what
it was not that long ago, you know?
We were just in lush
vegetation, very humid.
This has become quite arid and dry and...
But it still has this real
beauty and totally different,
too, to what we've been used to so far.
So, it's really really pretty cool.
What a beautiful country,
lovely people as well.
I mean, we just had the
most amazing experience
in the very first solar
farm here in Honduras
and they're doing some
20 watts right beside
a big power station that
burns heavy oil, or that,
you know, the slop after
that processing oil.
And they do 240.
But, you know, it was
just done and they said
that what they're trying to
do here in the next two years
is to try and become at least 50% reliant
on renewable resources and
they've got lots and lots
of different solar panel
farms and wind farms
and hydroelectric.
So they're really doing their bid.
And this country this small,
they need to look after themselves.
And the guy was super
keen to show us all about
what his little baby is doing
and what they're producing.
So, it's really lucky and lovely to see
and the really nice thing
about the whole thing
was that we were managed
to park up and we managed
to get, you know, half
an hour's charge up.
You know, we got four of 5% I think.
It's a little tough turn coming up-
- Yeah.
I saw a cute little one
struggling up the hill there.
(wind whistling)
Oh, talk about portaloos.
- Yeah.
They're just going down to
dump them in that place.
- Yeah, probably empty
there into the mount.
- 70 miles to go.
- Okay.
Well, I think that town, I can't remember
how many short was it.
- It's about 30 mile, 25
mile, 20 mile, 30 miles short.
- Okay.
- 20 odd miles short.
- And that's where your-
- That's where the pizza place was.
- So that's 50 miles away.
- Yeah.
- And now I've only got
44 miles on my bike,
but then I'm going up a hill.
- Yeah, and we've got 50%,
so we've already done about 60 miles.
- Right.
- Today, because it was
140 altogether, wasn't it?
- Yeah.
- So, we've done sort of half, really.
- Yeah, if we got 50 miles left.
So, I've got 70 miles to the hotel,
then 50 miles must be to that
place-ish.
- Yeah.
(wind rustling)
- It's sort of eerie being
on this road so empty.
- I know, that just seems
to be there's a feeling
of life that's not quite right today.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I have to say, I'm so glad
we're riding it, though.
I mean, it's what we're
here for, it's so cool.
- Yeah, no, it's a much better plan than-
- Yeah, if we'd flown we would've
missed all this, you know?
(wind rustling)
- It's 46 miles to that town.
- Okay. Yeah, yeah, my
mileage has gone up already.
- Well, we're 1,000 feet.
- Yeah, wow.
- That's right, yeah.
Climbed up a lot.
Ah.
- You all right?
- Ah, I just got stung. Hang on.
- You got stung?
- Yeah.
Ow.
(man groans)
- Where'd you get stung? On your arm?
- Just under my eye.
- Oh.
- Let's see if you can see it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Hang on.
- Yep, there it is,
don't move, don't move.
There we go.
- Get it?
- Yep, that's the sting there.
It's gonna swell up.
- Have you got any-
- Antihistamines?
- Yeah, take it straight
away. Have you got it?
- Yeah.
How'd it manage to smash into
my face and sting me as well?
- Well, I suggest that he
saw your face coming in
and he just curled his butt up.
- Yeah, because I'm going-
- You're going with me.
Let's just put it this way,
it's gonna make you look manly, okay?
- More manly.
- Yeah, more. Yeah, more manly.
Yeah, of course, I mean, you know.
(both laughing)
- Should we carry on or?
- Yeah, I think we just cruise on.
(engine rumbling)
(wind whistling)
- 'Cause you got the
forward facing camera on
and you can film it as
it starts to expand.
- As it starts to what?
- As it starts to swell.
- Oh, yeah.
- Like a time lapse thing.
- Yeah, a time lapse.
(wind whistling)
- Oh my God, okay.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I was only joking about the road ending,
but here it ends.
- How's your cheek?
- Well, smart a bit.
I mean, it feels like-
- Like they'd been stung?
- Yeah, I just hope that
the antihistamine kicks in
'cause like my face just swells up.
Like I've got stung on the eye once before
and both eyes shut, you know?
I looked like I'd been in a boxing match.
But I don't think... I'm pretty sure...
Well, hopefully the antihistamines-
- Did you get some antihistamines
when they both swelled up?
- No, no.
I was a kid.
It was like, put vinegar
on it or something.
- Right.
- Oh my god, what a skinny dog up here.
I can't get my camera to work.
- I think mine's running
out of my pockets right now,
but I think I managed
to get it on manually.
Boy, that dog's in terrible shape.
- Skinny, skinny dog.
- Well, I think that's
a bit of tarmac there.
- Okay.
- Oh no.
Okay, that's good.
That'll do.
I'll take it, I'll take it.
- Take it, marvelous.
Now, go over the hill
here and there's a big-
- McDonald's.
(man laughs)
(wind rustling)
- I wonder if that's Claudio crackling in.
- Yeah, maybe.
Look at this width of this road.
I mean, why?
Like they're drawing corn
or drying corn on it.
Did you see that guy with the crucifix
on the right there and on
the left with the cowboy hat?
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Very nice.
(wind whistling)
- Well, in 30 something miles is that town
where that Pizza Hut place is.
- Oh.
- There's noted places there.
- No, but maybe we just head there.
- That's 37 miles.
- Well, I'll make that.
- 36 miles now, so we should make that.
- Well, maybe we just head
to that, plug in there.
(wind rustling)
- I wonder why they didn't
just do that middle bit.
So strange.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, these are all
indigenous pine trees.
- You know, we're 1,700 feet.
(wind rustling)
I don't think we'll get much higher.
- Yeah.
- I don't think they're
expecting all this road
in the wash house.
All that kinda...
- A little drop down there, guys.
On the corner.
- Yeah.
- It's all a bit yellow
brick road up here,
I feel like we're in the
"Wizard of Oz" or something.
- Yeah.
- Much better tarmac
there, oh my goodness.
(wind rustling)
I wasn't expecting this
scenery or this road.
This is great, it's like a
little surprise adventure.
- That's pretty.
(man yawns)
I'm hungry.
So...
(wind rustling)
Hey.
You wanna come up to about 40, Ewan?
- Yep.
- Hang on. Sorry, I'm at 42.
40 now.
- Doesn't it remind you of
sort of Yellowstone Park
or something in the States?
- I know.
It's really spectacular, isn't it?
- Spectacular.
- All I need is a really nice
salad bar down here, you know.
- Yeah.
- And an ice cream place.
That's all.
- Wow, there's a lot of
walking to back here.
- Yeah.
I like the way they did the concrete
with the stones in it down here and-
- Did you see that?
(wind whistling)
- Watch, there's something up ahead.
Cowboys, something.
A little pow wow.
- A little cowboy conference.
- Camel?
- Camels.
(wind whistling)
(man whistles)
- Oh, should we go up to 481?
Should we go back up?
- Yeah.
- What have you got on your clock?
35 on here.
- 33 miles.
(wind rustling)
(man coughs)
- Oh, hang on.
Okay.
What do you have?
(wind rustling)
- Oh, a bit of regen.
A bit of regeneration.
- Okay, coming up.
- Okay, slowing down.
- Coming up.
Slowing down, coming up.
- Oh, here's a bit of gravel.
- Okay, be careful everyone.
(wind whistling)
- I think we need to go on
the other side of the road.
Yeah, look.
Yeah, down here.
This is the key here.
Or is it...
Okay.
- I think it's probably best to go
single track here, boys and girls.
- Yes, stay over to the right.
- Oh yeah.
(wind howling)
Look at this valley.
Stunning, huh?
- Yeah.
- I guess we missed the town.
- The one with a C?
- Yeah, the first one, you know?
- Yeah.
Well, do you wanna just lead
us into your pizza place?
- Yeah, I've got it in my
thing which is 20... 23 miles.
- Okay.
- And I've got 32 on the clock.
- I got 29.
Okay.
- So.
- So, we really are bingo
where we've gotta decide whether...
Well, let's see what mileage
we've got when we get there.
How much have you got on yours?
'Cause you've got the
end destination, right?
- Yeah, it says...
To the end it says 44 miles.
- Okay.
- So we don't have
to put in an hour.
- Yeah.
- Now there's another lane on
the other side of the road.
Now I feel like we're...
- Yeah.
- Oh well.
- Nothing we can do about it now.
- No, but we can cross over here.
- Okay, let's do it.
- It is very odd, isn't it?
- I'm still amazed at how the iPhone
still follows the road exactly.
(wind rustling)
(wind whistling)